[Musik]
auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge
aber
Thomas hast du die letzte von den Rollen
da gebraucht weißt du das also ich meine
das letzte Papier von der Rolle bin ich
Küchendienst nein
bei den Auswanderern in Kanada liegen
die Nerven blank
das ist besser war in der Schweiz war
nein das sagt hier gar niemanden
du so gehen und soll ich meine oder nee
das habe ich auch nie gesagt ich habe
gesagt ich würde das so wie wir es
gemacht haben würde ich nicht wieder
machen
ein luxuriöses Gästehaus am Meer das ist
der Traum von Barbara hasenbühler und
Thomas Range nach stark Schwierigkeiten
ist der Umbau der Villa endlich auf
gutem Weg
das ist wie das Schlaf Wohnzimmer
[Musik]
den Knöchel
und obwohl noch kein einziges Zimmer
fertig ist haben Sie bereits jede Menge
Buchungen
im sonnigen Griechenland wollen aller
egerter und Anita Thomi Ferien für
Reptilienfreunde anbieten
doch alles kommt anders ein verheerender
Waldbrand vernichtet das Haus der
Auswanderer
Schlafzimmer gesehen sie verlieren alles
trotzdem geben Sie nicht auf und
beginnen mit dem Wiederaufbau
[Musik]
auch das Tourismusgeschäft wollen sie
starten sie bieten eine erste
Erlebnisreise an da habe ich auch kurze
erzählt dass die Unterkunft noch nicht
bei uns ist wegen dem Brand
mehr Selbstbestimmung sucht Familie
Rotzler in Schweden übernehmen sie eine
Ferienanlage und mit ihr jede Menge
Arbeit
als erstes renovieren sie die Gaststube
immer mit dabei Nachbar 11
Spaß
müssen sich als Gastgeber bewähren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sieben Wochen später sieben Wochen in
denen sich manches verändert hat
vielleicht Finke
[Musik]
für Tochter Fiona beginnt morgen die
Schule aber ausgerechnet jetzt ist die
sechsjährige krank
die ganze Nacht ist sie eigentlich wach
sind Herr kätzle
klassisch
mit deinem Mann ist einfach überhaupt
über alles Einhörner
jetzt haben wir es einfach einmal parat
gemacht und jetzt hoffe mir dass der
heute Nachmittag schon viel besser
gemacht
nach dem erfolgreichen Testlauf mit
ersten Gästen sind trotz las nicht
untätig gewesen
sie haben den defekten Hotpot abgebaut
und durch einen neuen Kessel ersetzt
[Musik]
in der Gaststube haben sie Teppichboden
verlegt und alles frisch mit Fundstücken
aus der Anlage dekoriert
jetzt fehlt nicht mehr viel schon bald
wollen sie das Restaurant nicht nur für
Hotelgäste sondern auch für
Laufkundschaft öffnen
trotz der vielen Arbeit den Umzug nach
Mittelschweden bereut der ehemalige
Qualitätsmanager nicht
schon allein
mit der Kind rufst du
und und mit Kinder zum Mittagessen mit
der Kinder
aber sie sind unbedingt
[Musik]
heute möchte Jonas einen Sichtschutz
Bauen mit Holz aus dem eigenen Wald das
große Grundstück war auch ein Grund
warum sich rotzlars für ein Leben in
Schweden entschieden haben
als Unternehmer können rotzlas den Tag
selbst gestalten und machen was sie für
richtig erachten ohne Chef im Nacken das
genießen Sie besonders
[Musik]
Sabrina möchte mit Kian und Liana Beeren
sammeln diese wachsen überall auf ihrem
Grundstücke
Silvana die Patentante von Kian kommt
mit sie ist eine Woche bei rosslas zu
Besuch und unterstützt die Familie
Deutsch ganz viel Moos hier und dort
sicherer
obwohl die Familie erst einen Sommer in
Schweden verbracht hat ist das alte
Leben im solotonischen Witterswil schon
ganz weit weg
t ich warten
oder so aber
irgendwie ist das große vermisse ich bis
jetzt auch ausblebe wenn wir uns einfach
sehr wohl fühlen
eigentlich fast jeden Tag ja immer nur
relativ oft ja
[Musik]
auf dem griechischen Peloponnes steht
der Frühling vor der Tür
seid gut acht Monaten Leben Anita Thomi
und Allah algerta schon in der
Einliegerwohnung von Holländer Hans
und nicht nur sie sondern auch 15
Reptilien draußen ist es für die Tiere
immer noch zu frostig
Lucy komm
ja
wenn es regnet
unglaublich fest und ich habe eigentlich
nicht
mit Freunden
[Musik]
die Schweizer sind dankbar dass Hans sie
aufgenommen hat trotzdem macht sich bei
den beiden langsam so etwas wie Lager
Koller breit
ihr sehnlichster Wunsch so schnell wie
möglich wieder auf ihrem eigenen
Grundstück wohnen
was noch fehlt sind die Hilfsgelder für
den Wiederaufbau schon vor Wochen haben
sie den Antrag bei den griechischen
Behörden gestellt
[Musik]
zumindest die Löcher für die
schildkrötenteiche konnten Sie bereits
ausheben lassen und das Sanitärhaus ist
ebenfalls fast fertig
gut versteckt die wichtigsten Neuerung
[Musik]
heute wollen sie den Wohnwagen
ausrichten den sie aus der Schweiz
mitgebracht haben
wenn es wieder wärmer ist wollen sie ihn
als Büro und Schlafplatz nutzen das
Problem der Wohnwagen steht viel zu
schräg
so
jetzt hier auseinander
[Musik]
nach zwei Stunden Steine schleppen geht
es plötzlich ganz schnell
[Musik]
zahlen wird der Dinge die geschehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
23 Grad und Sonnenschein auf Prinz
Edward Island beginnt die Hauptsaison
nur noch vier Tage dann wollen Thomas
Range und Barbara hasenmöhler ihr
Gästehaus eröffnen
doch noch ist nicht alles fertig okay
es ist Wochenende und die Handwerker
machen frei
Barbara und Thomas aber müssen
durcharbeiten wie schon so oft in
letzter Zeit
was gut wäre aber jetzt ein Tag frei und
einfach irgendwann mal machen worauf ich
jetzt wirklich Lust hätte keine Ahnung
das Fahrrad wieder setzen oder einfach
irgendwie
Strand laufen
wie das wird sicher viel bringen und
die Batterien wieder aufladen aber
muss man
einfach realistisch sein sondern das ist
einfach im Moment liegt das nicht drin
[Musik]
die Außenarbeiten an der 570
Quadratmeter großen Villa sind fast
abgeschlossen
[Musik]
schon für Gäste herrichten konnten
Barbara und Thomas die Bibliothek über
Monate diente sie ihn als Schlafzimmer
ist noch nicht ganz verheilt aber
zumindest der Gips ist weg
endlich kann sich die 45-Jährige wieder
frei im ganzen Haus bewegen
die beiden wohnen jetzt gleich neben der
Küche sie wollen für Gäste erreichbar
sein
aber im Moment ist es einfach
Abstellkammer
großer Rückzugsraum ist schon
ausgestattet
ganz im Gegensatz zu den Hotelzimmern
neben verschiedenen Details fehlt noch
etwas ganz Entscheidendes die Möbel
fast die gesamte Einrichtung hat Barbara
in China auf Maß herstellen lassen
knapp vier Wochen in Halifax gestrandet
und das bedeutet es mir seit drei Wochen
und würde mich so viel Scheiß erlaubt
hat die letzten
Monat und jetzt die letzte drei Wochen
ganze
ausgerechnet ihr Container wurde vom
Zoll in Halifax aus tausenden ausgewählt
jetzt wird er einer Sonderprüfung
unterzogen
diese kostet nicht nur Zeit sondern auch
viel Geld
10.000 kanadische Dollar oben drauf
[Applaus]
soll ich dir helfen
ihnen bleibt nur eins Augen zu und
gemeinsam durch so wie neu
Grundstabilität vorhanden
auf der Ferienanlage
vorbeigekommen und angemeldet
im Anhänger ein Schneemobil
Ulf möchte es reinigen und bei Jonas in
der Garage einlagern so wie all die
Jahre zuvor
im Restaurant kümmert sich Jonas um
letzte Details wäre es wie vor ein paar
Wochen stünde 11 nun an Jonas Seite doch
die Beziehung zwischen rotzlars und
ihrem Nachbarn ist nicht mehr so eng wie
zu Beginn
noch vor dem Verkauf erhielt Öl vom
Vorbesitzer einen Schlüssel für die
Ferienanlage seitdem geht Öl 4 ein und
aus wie es ihm passt
Öl Fett am Anfang immer ganz toll cool
ja macht er jetzt wirklich nicht
tun bis dahinter unten
irgendwie
oder verkaufen das ist von Anfang
geschafft und wir hätten uns Wünsche das
iPhone einfach offen kommuniziert
die Idee von Öl fanden rotzlas
eigentlich nicht schlecht aber mit jedem
weiteren Tag benahm er sich ein wenig
mehr wie ein Mitbesitzer der Anlage
Karten
ein Stelle von 11 geht nun Sabrina Jonas
zur Hand
Ofen in den Lagerschuppen der Anlage
gibt es alte Ski zu Haus bei Langläufern
was Gosche Garden einst sehr beliebt
[Applaus]
ganze Skifahren
[Musik]
Sabrina und Jonas versuchen Konflikte
offen anzusprechen das haben sie auch
bei Nachbar Öl von seiner Frau Eva
gemacht
offenbar mit Erfolg
a
ja
rotzlars wollen auch weiterhin gut mit
Öl und Eva auskommen was das Geschäft
anbelangt gehen Sie jedoch lieber ihren
eigenen Weg
[Musik]
auf dem griechischen Peloponnes ruht für
einmal bei aller und Anita die Arbeit
denn heute erwarten die Auswanderer
erste Gäste
eine Gruppe aus der Schweiz hat bei
Ihnen eine Erlebnisreise gebucht
eine Woche lang wollen Anita und aller
den Reisenden ihren neue Heimat zeigen
okay
trotz der Feuerkatastrophe Anita fühlt
sich in coroni wohl
das ist schon nicht der Ort wo wir kein
Glück brauchte
mit dem hier leben
[Musik]
noch ist hier alles im Winterschlaf nur
vereinzelt verirren sich Touristen in
die Gassen des Fischerdorfes ganz anders
im Sommer dann ist coroni ein beliebter
Ferienort
[Musik]
allah ist unterwegs in das 50 km
entfernte Kalamata dort gibt es einen
internationalen Flughafen
[Musik]
immerhin die Hälfte der Gäste kennt
allein bereits aus der reptilienszene
aller prüfte im Emmental jahrelang
elektrische Anlagen in Griechenland
musste sich nun als Reiseleiter beweisen
[Gelächter]
die sechs Gäste sind Mitglieder bei den
schildkrötenfreunden Aargau nach dem
Brand hat der Verein großzügig für aller
und Anita gespendet so wie viele andere
Bekannte und Freunde
die Schweizer kommen zwei Monate früher
als geplant auf eigenen Wunsch obwohl
die Temperaturen für die Reptilien
Beobachtung noch nicht ideal sind
[Musik]
für die Gruppe haben Anita und aller ein
Apartment gemietet in der Zukunft wollen
sie Gäste in fünf eigenen Ferienhäuschen
beherbergen
[Musik]
von einem gemütlichen Apero mit ersten
Gästen können die Auswanderer in Kanada
nur träumen
anstatt einzurichten bangen Barbara und
Thomas weiterhin um Ihre Möbel die
Zollbehörde hat die Kontrolle zwar
abgeschlossen den Container aber immer
noch nicht freigegeben die endlose
Warterei ziert an den Nerven also
hier ist alles fertig
doch hat mit wirklicher
alles was sie besitzen haben Barbara und
Thomas in das Projekt mit dem Gästehaus
gesteckt jetzt müssen sie so schnell wie
möglich Geld verdienen Hasen
her ich weiß wo du anfangen könntest mit
Putzen ich weiß wo du richtig putzen
könntest ich putze jetzt nicht ich baue
jetzt da die blöde Hundegitter auf aber
nachher wenn du das runter geht
aufgebaut hast bis 18 Uhr nein ist es
nicht das ist noch nicht mal halb eins
also was willst du mir erklären
ist komplett bis aufs Badzimmer gemacht
alles alles ist alles gestrichen die
Schränke sind fertig zusammengestellt
da ist alles perfekt
trotz sorgfältiger Planung wird die
To-Do-Liste der beiden einfach nicht
kürzer
weil da müssen die Maler nicht mehr rein
hallo
hallo Hase
den Zaun hat Barbara im Internet
bestellt sobald ihr Gästehaus offen ist
dürfen die Möpse nicht mehr frei auf dem
Gelände herumlaufen
[Musik]
was einfach aussieht ist bei diesen
Bedingungen jedoch alles andere als
leicht
genau deswegen hören wir jetzt auf damit
das ist eine Sache die ich leider jetzt
an der Stelle wirklich nicht lösen kann
es ist von der Idee her gut aber es ist
einfach zu wenig und ich habe im Moment
dafür keine Lösung habe ich einfach
nicht
Geld dafür tut mir leid
aber da müssen wir uns was anderes
überlegen
also ich bin in der 7 das Soundprojekt
ist so nicht realisierbar was immer die
Lösung ist ich habe keine ich mache
jetzt die sieben danke
die knappe Zeit der wirtschaftliche
Druck die viele Arbeit
thomas hat sich den Start ihres
Gästehauses anders vorgestellt
[Musik]
6:30 Uhr in der Früh in Schweden
das Fieber ist weg und Fiona ist fit
genug für ihren ersten Schultag
ich bin eigentlich nicht
sie wird es gut machen
in der Schweiz könnte Fiona zur
Primarschule laufen das nächste
Schulhaus in Schweden jedoch ist rund 25
km entfernt
kleine Schuhe wo wenig Kinder sind nur
wenig Lützen also verhältnismäßig wo
jeder jede kennt auch über die
verschiedenen Klassen hinweg auf dem
Lehrpersonal
dankt euch genauso richtige
[Musik]
an der Wickie Force skola werden knapp
50 Kinder unterrichtet es
und willkommen
hey hey
Klassenlehrerin Victoria erwartet Fiona
bereits
schön dass wir gesund bist
jetzt heißt es Rechnen Lesen Schreiben
lernen und das alles auf schwedisch
[Musik]
alles gut
damit es Fiona leichter fällt hat
Sabrina mit ihr bereits seit einigen
Wochen schwedisch geübt
[Musik]
unbemerkt von Fiona schleicht sich
Sabrina davon
mega hart jetzt für sie für mich auch
aber es ist besser weil sonst wir sind
mit die ganze Zeit
[Musik]
die Blumen können fast ein wenig darüber
hinwegtäuschen wie kühl es noch immer
ist kaum 15 Grad im Schatten zeigt das
Thermometer in Griechenland
damit zu der Mühle
aller und Anita führen die Reisegruppe
auf eine Exkursion aufspüren
so schnell gibt Allah nicht auf er weiß
genau wo er suchen muss
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
mit ihren Gästen wollen Allah und Anita
zu einem versteckten Wasserfall als sie
das letzte Mal dort waren wimmelte es im
Wasser von Schildkröten
[Musik]
westkaspische Schildkröten Leben am Fuße
des Wasserfalls
[Applaus]
geschultes
keine
Landschaft genau
[Musik]
in Schweden hat Fiona eine Lektion
draußen im Kindergarten in Witterswil
mochte sie das am liebsten
[Musik]
die Kinder sind bis am frühen Nachmittag
in der Schule doch heute holt Sabrina
ihre Tochter schon kurz vor dem
Mittagessen ab
so hat es Sabrina mit Klassenlehrerin
Victoria vereinbartner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der ersten Woche wird Sabrina ihre
Tochter mit dem Auto fahren dann soll
Fiona den Schulbus nehmen
[Musik]
ist gut gegangen ja
so schlimm gesehen aber sie will
trotzdem morgen kochen
der erste Schultag ist geschafft
Jonas und Sabrina hoffen dass sich Fiona
schnell in der neuen Schule Einleben
wird
[Musik]
nach Sonnenuntergang Unternehmen Aneta
und aller in Griechenland einen neuen
Anlauf diesmal suchen sie mit ihrer
Reisegruppe nach Chamäleons
[Musik]
wenn es dunkel ist kann man Chamäleons
besser sehen
anheben Sie sich von der Umgebung ab
so zumindest die Theorie
Allah würde sich über ein
Erfolgserlebnis freuen aber auch hier
ist es anscheinend für die Tiere noch zu
kalt
auf einmal macht sich Aufregung breit
sehr schön
[Musik]
das Basilisken Chamäleon gibt es in
Europa nur an diesem Ort
[Musik]
sein eigentlicher Lebensraum liegt in
Afrika
[Musik]
der Wind in Kanada ist weg
und der Hundezaun steht
der Container mit den Möbeln aber fehlt
nach wie vor und ohne Möbel keine
Eröffnung
bis zur Ankunft der ersten Gäste bleiben
Thomas und Barbara nur noch zwei Tage
an unsere Stimmung an dem wie wir
miteinander umgehen um einfach sich
wirklich fragen muss warum
um alles in der Welt tun wir uns das
hier eigentlich wirklich an ist es das
wirklich wert
und als hätten die beiden nicht schon
genug Probleme taucht ein weiteres auf
in den Gästezimmern gibt es kein heißes
Wasser die Installation der Fabrik neuen
Durchlauf Erhitzer scheint in Ordnung
doch wo liegt der Fehler
[Musik]
das Problem es gab ein Missverständnis
zwischen Sanitär und Elektriker
kann man richtig noch was ändern
der Elektriker hat zu dünne Stromkabel
verlegt
it is like
nights
kein heißes Wasser und keine Möbel
schlimmer kann es fast nicht mehr kommen
ein Wechselbad der Gefühle die beiden
brauchen weiterhin starke Nerven
in der nächsten Folge Treffen nach
langem Warten die Möbel ein ein riesiger
Überseecontainer randvoll mit Kartons
Barbara und Thomas bleiben weniger als
36 Stunden um alles einzurichten
[Musik]
um Gäste zu begeistern ist mit
Sicherheit mindestens eins von diesen
hier
in Griechenland bereiten aller und Anita
die Bodenplatte für die Maurer vor der
Wiederaufbau ihres Wohnhauses soll jetzt
so schnell wie möglich starten
für der Subventionen
bekommen die Wasserschildkröten die
Emmentaler feiern die Einweihung der
Teiche mit einem Fest und los
und erster Schnee in Schweden Jonas muss
die Langlaufloipen
organisieren einen Weihnachtsmarkt für
die lokale Bevölkerung
das Restaurant im skull Schuh Gordon ist
so voll wie noch nie
[Musik]
wo sie stehen
[Applaus]
auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge